okay thank you very much and uh let me
uh i was talking about sources for this
material there are several research
papers
and there is also an expensive
computational study that has just been
completed that can be found off from my
website
it was just published uh with my uh some
some of my collaborators at asu uh
stephanie gill who is now at harvard
uh and uh her students schmidt about
australia
uh
and let me also mention this talk is
going to be for 30 minutes
but there's an hour one hour version of
this talk that
recorded recently and can be found that
youtube is successful from my website in
case you want to see more details
so here's my outline i'm going to talk
about multi-agent problems in general
then give a dynamic programming
formulation for addressing them
then the key part for this talk is a new
type of consideration
which involves agent by agent policy
improvement and i'm going to talk about
the exact version of this
method method and then an approximate
version which uses neural networks
value and policy networks uh then
uh i'm going to talk about how you
introduce autonomy into
the algorithm so that the agents don't
have to communicate
as much and then i'm going to talk about
the multi-robot repair problem that i
mentioned the previous slide
and give you some computational results
and i also have a video
and i hope it works and
and i hope also that i will have enough
time to do that
so let me talk about multi-asian
problems
it is a very old in
well-researched field days from the 60s
was not called multi-agent then it was
called the team theory
decentralized control with a very active
field
and it relates to a situation where you
have
multiple decision centers what we call
agents
and each one has its own decision
variable this views that you see here
and they collect information
and exchange information to the
environment or from each other
and at every time step they apply
a decision each agent applies a decision
agent i
applies in ui sequentially in discrete
time
based on the information that's received
so
what they do at time zero they have some
information they apply the first
the first decision the first control
then they collect information
and then at time one they apply a second
control
and then input new information again a
third control and so on so the
discrete time system but the
characteristic
is that we that the the
control or decision variable has
multiple components one per agent
now this diagram here includes a very
large collection of problems
and there's a major fundamental
distribution between
the different structures that they can
appear with economics of this problem
this was known back in the 60s
and one of the names that you will see
referenced in connection with mrs vinson
housing
wrote some fundamental papers about this
distinction
and there are two structures one is the
classical information pattern
where the agents are fully cooperative
they
fully share their information
and they never forget the information
and this is the case that's being
treated that can be treated by dynamic
programming
this is the quote unquote easy case
although it's
usually not that easy but it's the easy
case as compared
to the other structure which is the
non-classical information
pattern where the agents do not have
common information
and also they may be antagonistic
although we're going to talk about the
cooperative phase here
and this case is hard
very hard and the reason is that in
contrast to a classical information
pattern it cannot be treated by dynamic
program
there is no dynamic programming
algorithm that can be used in connection
with this non-classical information
pattern
and this makes the problem uh very hard
and just to give you a personal sense of
this
i have actually worked on this problem
when i was a phd
student that was 50 years ago and i
spent
six months working quite intensively on
this problem
and i gave up and the reason was i
realized the problem is so hard that
i cannot possibly get a result that will
be
that will be strong a strong result so i
gave up
worked on something else but the field
went on strong
in the 70s and then in the 80s it
sort of started losing steam
uh because people were getting some
theoretical results but um
they could not uh
these results were not very applicable
particularly with the computers of the
day
so this field stayed somewhat dormant
uh up to the up to about 15
20 years ago when reinforcement learning
came along
and introduced its own brand of of
uh algorithmic approximations and uh the
problem did not become any easier
but uh people were less afraid of it
let's take let's put it back there
um we
are going to start with the classical
information pattern
however we will introduce a framework
that admits generalization to some
extent to the non-classroom coordination
path
so remember here that the agents have
exact state information
choose their controls as functions of
the state
and they share the same information so
conceptually we can view this as being
as having some kind of a computational
cloud that collects
all the information from the environment
from the agents
and then beams back to the agents some
state information whatever they need to
know
in order to apply uh to apply a control
and we
are going to uh
assume a model that's standard in
dynamic programming
it involves state text and control u
we're going to focus on discounted
infant correlation problems which are
stochastic
and the characteristic of this
model which sets it apart from general
dynamic programming models
is that the control has
multiple components m components each
component corresponding to an agent
and agents here is just a a conceptual
metaphor
the important mathematical structure is
the multi-component
structure these components may
correspond to
multiple robots going around the field
doing things
or they may just be a single robot
having m
arms that are that are controlled
individually
by this uh this this new components
and our theoretical framework is dynamic
programming
uh this is the nice consequence of
having a classical information path
and our initial aim is gonna be very
simple
we're going to aim at
faster computation we have a difficult
problem we're going to try to make the
computation go faster
and one of the issues we're going to
deal with is the exponential size
of the search space here we have
multiple components so the size
of the the number of controls grows
exponentially
with a number of agents this can
introduce prohibited computation
in many times many types of dynamic
programming operations including
minimization of the belmont equation
the second issue that we're going to
address
is an issue for autonomy we want to have
the agent's
computer controls in parallel
so that so that we gain by
parallelization
being a speed up and in the process
we're going to deal in part with the
non-classical information patterns
so that's where we are going and let me
give you an example of a problem
uh of this type um
it's representative of many types of
problems like multi-robot
delivery problems multi-level
maintenance
search and rescue firefighting and so on
but to make it
more interesting we're going to
introduce in terms of spiders and flies
so what we have here is 15 spiders
they move in the four directions on a
grid
and or they can stay where they are and
they have perpetration in other words
they know where all these
other spiders are and they also
know where the flies are that's
implies here which are passive
and blind and they just move randomly
they don't do anything purposely
and the objective is to catch the flies
in minimum time so now
the size of the control space each of
these
spiders has five choices
uh have five motion choices about 15 of
them
so the number of joint possible moves
again in one state is five to the 15.
it's an enormous number and
so in terms of q learning this means 5
to the 15 2 factors at a given state
to compare what we're going to do
is reduce this from 5 to the 15 to 5
times 15 while still maintaining
good properties in the context of policy
iteration
and other dynamic programming related
algorithms
and the idea is to break down the
control into a sequence
of one spider at a time moves so
within this context we introduce a
border
in of the flies of these spiders
and the first spider makes
its move and broadcasts
this move to all the other spiders the
second spider
now makes its move taking into account
the move of the first spider
and then after it selects the move
broadcast
this move to the other spiders and we go
through this 15 times one spider at a
time
so the total number of uh comparisons
that we have to make for this
is 15 spiders five comparisons a piece
so it's five to the fifteen
now in this process there is
serial computation involved because the
spiders
select their moves uh one at a time
we would like ideally to give some
autonomy to the spiders
so what we're going to do is uh
introduce
some coordination information that will
play the role of communicating and
broadcasting the spider
moves this this can be viewed as
signaling which is
pre-computed and it's going to be
available possibly through neural
networks
so that the 15 spiders will choose moves
in parallel which gives us an extra
speed of factor of 15.
i'm going to come back to this problem
of spiders implies later
so let me now introduce the dynamic
programming formulation
in this talk i'm going to focus on
finite statement horizon problems with
discounting
so we have um a system a discrete time
system
which has state xk control uk
and there's a random parameter wk
and we move from an initial state x0
to a sequence of states from xk to xk
plus 1
using this system equation and there is
a random cost associated with transition
that involves also a discount factor
alpha alpha to the k at the case stage
and we're interested in policies which
are multi-components okay
the control has m components and we want
to find a policy which is
m functions um that map
the state x to the control components
that
must satisfy some constraint and
given upon c mu we accumulate the cost
over an infinite number of stages take
the limit as
the number of goes to infinity and and
we obtain
the cost of a policy at a given initial
state
so this is the cost function of the
policy of a policy mu
j mu and we want to find the optimal
cost function which i'm denoting here by
j star and
the fundamental result here revolves
around dominance equation
uh the right hand side of bellman's
equation is the expression
minimization overall controls of the q
factor corresponding to all the two
factors
over all the few factors corresponding
to a state
x and if we do that
with j star being here then we obtain an
optimal policy
so this is a fundamental result very
nice but there are some problems with it
we need to know jstar which is extremely
hard to find
in fact the whole object of
reinforcement learning is how to make
approximations to jstar
that they're sort of adequate but
there's a second difficulty here
we minimize overall possible controls
and remember the search space
is grows exponentially with a number of
with a number of agents so this
minimization is also a difficulty
so staying again with the exact version
of this
problem let's talk about policy duration
consideration generates a sequence of
policies
starting from a given policy which i'm
going to call base policy new
we evaluate it compute this cost
function
and then we improve it by minimizing in
balancing equation
but with j mu replacing the j star
uh this is a minimization that's
possible to do because if necessary we
can
calculate h and u by simulation and
if we do this minimization for every
state
we obtain a new policy which i'm calling
the rollout policy
so that's the definition of the rollout
policy we have the base policy new we
evaluate j mu and then we improve it by
minimizing in this expression
is expected value over w and
the fundamental policy improvement
property
is that the rollout policy is uniformly
better than the base policy
okay the term rollout the term is
is was initially introduced by
soro in the context of backgammon in the
mid 90s
uh in the context in exactly the same
context
as i am uh discussing here as the new
policy generated by policy improvement
on a base policy now the term rollout
has been used in many other different
ways
in the in the literature for this talk
the rollout algorithm is simply one
iteration
of the standard policy iteration
algorithm
in the instead of going through this
many times we go through this all
only once using some base points
and um it can be implemented online
if these values of j u are available
perhaps approximately through simulation
perhaps you can charge with 10 neural
network
and rollout has another
important advantage in addition to
policy
improvement it has robustly
it is robust with respect to
runtime one of the uncertainty in other
words
uh even though we have a certain model
that model may change the real system
may change over time
and we may record these changes and
encode them in this simulation field
called
calculations expected value so even
though
mu does not change the rollout policy
takes takes into account the changes
of the in in the model
and implements online reclining
that's an important advantage and not
all methods have disadvantage
so now let's uh let me give you an
outline of our approach
for multi-agent problems we start with
the classical information pattern
and we're going to propose a new type of
policy narration method that involves
this new form of policy improvement
with one agent at a time minimizing
it uses a sequence of single component
minimization
and intermediate agent coordination in
the sense that
the agents compute their controls
and then they communicate them or make
them available to the other agents who
take them into account
when they compute their own controls
and we will view aloud as in the
previous slide as a single
online policy improvement starting from
a base policy
we compute a rollout policy based on
one one edge at a time minimization
and the base policy can compute a number
of different ways
uh a different method can be used to
compute the base policy
a policy gradient method or a random
search method
and this is precisely the approach
that's been used in the alpha zero
generate a sequence of policies and
online
when you play you use rollout
there is some the only difference is
that
there's there are no multiple agents in
alpha zero and also instead of
one at a time one agent at a time uh
simplification uh it uses monetary
research
but it's basically a policy iteration
method with a online rollout
now how do we go from the classical
information pattern to the non-classical
information
pattern basically we are missing
information in the non-classical
information pattern
so instead we use guesses and we treat
them as being
exact the guesses can be pre-computed
they may be policy policies for example
um signaling bodies i called them
earlier
and they can be computed possibly
through neural network training
and there's a lot of research in this
area and i'm going to give you an idea
of
what we have done in the context of
the case study that i mentioned earlier
okay so let me go into details about
this new type of policy
improvement the standard
rollout algorithm
given the base policy mu evaluates jmu
and minimizes over all possible controls
overall causing m doubles of controls uh
in this equation
finds the minimum q factor but the
problem is the number of few factors
grows exponentially with a number of
agents
and the proposed alternative which i'll
call
multi-agent rollout or multi-agent
policy variation
is to instead of this minimization
overall components simultaneously do
them one at a time
so we have this base policy and the
first
agent chooses a control
by minimizing over its own local
controls while
sending the controls of the other agents
to the base policy
now given the control of the first agent
we use it to compute the control of the
stacker nation
who minimizes over its own controls the
corresponding two factors setting all
the fuel the controls of the future
agents to the base policy
but the rollout control of the first
agent which
has already been computed so we're going
in this way
with m steps um going through all the
agents
and now when we calculate the number of
two factors that we have to compute
it is linear in m because in a certain
number but
agent and we do this 10 times
so there's an enormous speed up relative
to the
standard rollout and that's what we're
trying to take advantage of
now what's the theory for this it turns
out that there is theory if the theory
is quite old
there's a whole section in my
neurodynamic programming book from 1996
with john cyclist which deals with how
you trade off
complexity of the control space with
complexity of the state space
in particular we do the following trick
we take a stage that generates x k to x
k
plus 1 and we unfold the control action
one component at a time so we introduce
intermediate states here first apply the
first control
go to this state then the second control
to this state
and so on and at the very last uh
the very last choice of control we make
the transition to xk plus one
using this equation in the corresponding
course
so what we have here is a problem with
10 times more stages
and times more cost functions because it
introduces
we have introduced extra states in their
corresponding cost functions
however the controls are taken over a
much simpler
space on the other hand when you do roll
up
you don't care about the size of the
state space at
all because at each stage you are at a
single state
if you don't care where the other states
are and how many they are
you only look at a single state so
the the so
the fact that we have made the state
space more complicated
does not bother rollout at all
and the key theoretical fact is that
with this equivalent problem formulation
the cost improvement property is
maintained and why is that
because if you think about it the one i
agent at the time rollout
algorithm that i gave in the previous
slide is just the standard rollout
algorithm for this
reform related problem since this
reformulated problem is equivalent to
the original when you improved its cost
is the same as improving the cost of the
original problem hence we obtained
this cost improvement property
and as i noted earlier there's a
tremendous complexity reduction
the one step look ahead branching factor
of
of the standard royal out algorithm is
reduced from exponential
to linear where n is a number of
possible choices
for each of the components
okay so that's the theoretical idea and
you can build a lot of algorithms around
this reformulated problem
now i want to i want to give an
illustration of these two different
forms of rollout
um with the with
the video and i hope this will work okay
so here what we have is two spiders
four spiders and two flies
can you see that yes so
yes we can i can
so we're going to i'm going to show you
first
the standard rollout algorithm there are
the four spiders here they're in the
center
um what uh the baseball is
is a 3d policy a shortest path type of
policy
whereby the spiders go straight towards
the closest fly
they figure out what is the closest fly
and they go to that
each one goes to to its closest fly
and then and they keep going like that
they don't coordinate that's the main
thing they don't coordinate their
choices
so in this particular case where they
start out with
at the same same location
they will all go to the same fly because
they see this as their best target
and they don't coordinate ideally
however
what you'd like to see is that two of
the spiders are going to go towards one
fly and the other two are going to go
towards the other fly and also if
they're really smart
they may try to encircle it because
these flies move randomly
and they can it makes sense to try to
encircle them
so let me show you what the the base
quality does uh
okay so they they almost simultaneously
now they they they they go to the
closest
fly using the manhattan distance metric
so two of them prefer the horizontal in
case of a die
and to prefer the vertical so that's why
you see them split off and moving input
so now they've caught the first fly
right here and they start moving on
towards the second fly
no coordination here so i'm going to
stop it because it's going to take some
time i'm going to give you results
later now let's see what the
standard rollout will do
okay now immediately you see
a standard rod introduces some
intelligence into the scheme
whereby they split off and they go and
change different
flies and they also try to do some form
of
encirclement which will come out from
the algorithm much
better results and
i'm going to go also into the ancient
variation drawn out
the results are pretty much the same uh
asian by ancient rollout
does roughly the same things although
not quite exactly the same
again the spiders spread off and they go
towards um
try to encircle the flies and so on
so the summary of the results
okay the time to catch the flies the
base policy
takes 85 steps the standard rollout
takes only 34 steps
however at every move at every
time step it has to compare
an exponential number of choices
625 more choices
agent by agent rollout again has the
same performance
but requires only 20 move choices
so there's some uh substantial gain here
and i'm going to show another video
later that illustrates the same thing as
well
okay so now i have
we have the standard rollout in the
multi-agent rollout
and how do they compare uh
they produce different rollout policies
different sequences
in the context of policy narration and
one policy may be better than the other
there's no clear domination of one
method over the other
however the standard rollout requires
exponential search uh interactive
computation
even for a modest number of agents
and uh in our computational experiments
uh we find that asian by agent roll out
it performs bad as well as standard roll
out
and and it appears
that for many types of problems this um
this is true but there is no definitive
result
that will establish this one way or the
other
okay so this happens very interesting
only a few more minutes i think um
how many minutes well i mean
we're just about at the end now so just
a few minutes or about negative seven i
guess if you if you could
wrap up it's not a bit late
half an hour ago so quickly uh
yeah definitely i'm sorry about that
um this talk came from a talk it was
trimmed down to half an hour but not
quite enough
uh okay so we're in this topic of
comparing standard and multi-agent
rollout and how about multi-agent
policy narration uh it's the same type
of police duration but use agent-by-age
policy improvement
and it doesn't terminate with an optimal
policy instead it terminates with an
agent by asian document policy which is
a nash equilibrium
you view the agents of players with each
having the same cost function
and a nash equilibrium need not be
optimal
uh there is a convergence result which
establishes
for exact consideration distinctions
conversions and i have no result for
radar convergence
but let me go quickly through the use of
approximations
all of the preceding discussion was for
exact policy narration and exactly
allowed to introduce approximations we
have to
introduce an approximation to the
in the in the uh evaluation
step of public iteration and we do this
by using
some kind of a value acrylic network
neural network some other architecture
collecting value data from the base
policy through simulation and fitting a
neural network or some other
architecture
computing rollout controls and feeding a
policy network to those
and that's how we obtained an
approximate rollout policy
and then of course we don't have exact
ones improvement we have approximate
policy improvement
uh with with some agent
um and
we if we do this once then we obtain an
approximate form of wrote out if we do
it this
repeatedly then we obtain an approximate
form of multiple
of all this iteration and
uh and now if you want to do
polystyration it can only be done with
offline training because you can train
neural networks online
so so rollout can be done can be
implements an online algorithm but
approximate policy variations cannot
and incidentally alpha 0 uses a scheme
of this type
offline policy duration plus online
rollout so now
i'm going to spend just a little time
sorry we have to cut it cut it off there
because it's
connected sorry but i you know everyone
i really encourage you to ask
um questions in the chat messages or to
follow up by our email
um i um i would
uh i'm sorry that we don't have
additional time
okay so i want to
give up just a couple of bullets from
this concluding slide is not permissible
of course um okay
so um
our methods require the classical
information pattern however
is the it can they can be the basis for
extensions to the non-classical
information pattern
through this idea of pre-computed
signaling policies that i haven't talked
about but you can read about
and now i want to say something about
comparison with existing methods
uh in our computational study which
involves a very challenging problem bp
problem
um we have we have also
applied existing methods
and these are palm cp and despot
these are general pump vp type methods
involving a
long look ahead but no roll out
long long look ahead with pruning or
monte carlo research
desperate these methods are not well
suited for multiple agents desperate
gave up
at four agents could not solve problems
with four agents
pomcp was able to solve problems with
four ages
no more than four agents but
it gave results that were worse often
worse than
the base policy mod pg is a different
type of method based on policy gradient
ideas and it is applied
it applies to multi-agent problems
mypg just could not cope at all with our
problem
it was just doing very strange things we
worked very hard to make it work
but it simply would not work and would
give you much
worse results from the base policy we
contacted the authors of mark pg
what's what may be going wrong but
in all indications matt pg cannot solve
this type of multi robot repair problems
and not only that it doesn't do sensible
things at all
um so uh
you i i leave you with that and you can
read the computational results
from the paper that's posted my website
and uh
i welcome your questions i'm sorry about
the
taking over thank you so much for that
talking
um i think one thing i know it's always
uh personally frustrating when i don't
have enough time to share some of the
results i'm excited about so if you
wouldn't mind if you have a link to the
longer talk if it's been pre-recorded we
could put that in the chat messages and
that will also give a nice pointer to
people who
can see the the full the full version um
because we can make sure all the
attendees see that too
yeah everything is uh at my website and
if one goes that my website which they
should have no difficulty
um there's a there's a link to the new
book and also to
my earlier book on reinforcement
learning and
uh everything is very clearly given
there all the papers including
and the youtube one hour talk
that's wonderful